welcome to this video continuing the
courage of the candidates tournament and
we are already
what is it round e 11 yeah we're really
nearing the finish line and the game to
be examined in this video is kramnik
against talent so we have the 14th world
champion kramnik playing the 50 in the
world champion in a very crucial game
are not obviously leading the tournament
with a great score +3 3 wins no loss
where cronic has already suffered two
defeats and is actually on is it three
defeats actually he lost the h3 he lost
to Paul off to kayaking into spinner
yeah three defeats actually he's on -1
and has basically no chance to qualify
anymore this is just two little points
even with the wind it would be very
difficult in this game but see you let's
see what happened Kramnik playing
default and I'm not playing Knight f6 6
which is of course 1 main part of his
opening repertoire we had played this
laugh though earlier in this tournament
so this was the the second option that
was to be expected and also plays some
sharper who brings like the goon thought
for example but this would have been a
really strange choice as he certainly is
perfectly a ride with getting a solid
position kramnik playing the Catalan
yeah it would have been interesting to
see what and would have done after
Knight c3 my suspicion is Bishop e7
going for a super solid play but never
known yeah Kramnik going for the Catalan
and one of his main weapons for a number
of years now and yeah a lot goes for the
mainline Bishop e7 and castles this is
the most yeah let's say classical way to
deal with things for us to complete the
King side
then to capture on c4 yeah black here
mostly has two ways to continue to take
or not to take and there is also the
closed catalan with 97 and c6 which is
in the line that I have analyzed quite a
bit bit for the black side trying to
keep the game bit more on a bit more
interesting
keeping in mind yeah situation where you
actually want to win this black how to
how to do that with D takes d4 that's
tricky
I'm not played this d takes the form of
which is objectively the best move and
for the situation certainly also the the
fitting one not risking anything and
doing anything fancy yeah I mean here
white mostly plays the move Queen c2
after which like it was a six and now
white can capture or play a four this is
the Catalan main line and be played back
ramnik numerous times he played 95
however which is yeah as you can see
from the tree took a bit of time
deciding now what line to play and it's
a line that he had played before
chronic we can see that the following
moves actually had been played in last
year's candidates tournament and a
crucial game against ER na world
champion magnus carlsen yeah what's the
idea of 95 yeah it's very obvious like
wants to a wide wants to get the pawn
back and ideally right now taking it
with the night
if black cam is playing yeah some sort
of standard move let's say like c5
weiter enjoys a very comfortable
position after something like that with
this bishop putting the usual pressure
on the law they
and black is rather passive he always
with this this bad bishop on c8 that is
simply worse compared to the great g2
bishop after 95 Black has a very direct
method of play and this is probably the
the best way to play I have a soft spot
for the some what we are looking at
Queen d6 yeah which are sometimes play
and then blitz chess just to mention it
for the four black players who play this
position if you want some to irritate
your opponent then 26 can be a quite
useful move the idea is to go there and
then play a quick move d8 it's not so
terrible it looks a bit strange I admit
that but it's it's not so bad okay but
cry an artist wants to play oops
no wants to play that the best moves and
not try to trick the opponent 96 is
really a probably the best move it
directly attacks the d4 pawn and
therefore forces the action white cannot
take on c4 as it gives up the pawn so
you need to take on c6 after 96 and the
white has two ways to do it obviously
this also whoops
was not a six yes also this lion taking
with the night but in this situation
it's not so easy before white to get one
of those pawns Bishop c6 rupee eight is
red really active of like he will play
Bishop e7 next and has no problems
whatsoever and the other ideas include
93 but so this pawn you can protect for
a while as black and there is always
possible counter play against d4
yeah um the usual way to go is what is a
chronic play to take with the bishop and
then with the night so that you attack
the Queen that needs to move and now why
it takes 27
yeah what is a result of this of this
exchange yeah white has very good
chances to emerge with an extra pawn
good the c4 pawn is some very difficult
for black to to keep in fact the most
popular movie is the move Queen to f4
trying to get this immediately
there are various possible lines if I
have c5 something like that for example
could be played with white having a pawn
but like having a very good Bishop that
might be active on the long diagonal and
White has a somewhat weakened King side
of this lease given up his Bishop on g2
in this position in last year's
candidates tournament however kramnik
introduced a new idea Queen c2 and after
if I have you played rook t1 yeah
Townsend had to solve this over the
board and while he managed and at the
end managed to draw this this game this
was an interesting try but I think it's
mostly diffused by now chronic here
played another replayed night to a3 and
this is almost a novelty there are only
like two games and the database with
this move and yeah this was new to or
not he hadn't anticipated this idea and
he took a while and then played c5 yeah
again it is probably happening that
white will win upon as the c4 pawn is
just a bit too weak c5 however theme
seems to be the best reply white
basically needs to capture there is not
much else if white takes immediately
here black will get this rook t8 moving
which already feels rather comes to a
full black you will get d4 anyway
so c5 white captured green takes and the
Bishop to e3 this was the idea of the
stay connected with 93 now the Queen
needs to move and yeah there's more than
one possible square I think I'm a plated
plated plated finally played Queen to h5
this move has a very direct idea simply
to play Knight to g4 and this is also
why white cannot take on c4 him
immediately
this should lead to some some problems
if you look at this yeah white must play
h4 which in itself looks ugly but the
main issue is that Bishop a6 now is a
problem if you move the knight you're
going to get completely clobbered
something like that so you need to cover
it in a way let's say let's say b3 it
does not matter it's it's it's awful in
any case and here yeah black and like
that destroy a white structure
completely and this is just awful
completely ridiculous pawn structure so
white cannot take on c4 Kramnik prepared
that with f3 and this of course control
it's crucial squares so that the knight
cannot join in on g4 yeah I turn here I
think I don't defended very precisely he
played the move c3 black also can play
other things it's well known from the
from the related lines starting with 95
that black can get compensation and in
various ways for this pawn in the
press-conference Kramnik also hinted
that e5 could be okay for black which is
maybe true and he actually said that
this night a3 idea was an old idea that
he had found a couple of years ago and
yeah he pretty much spontaneously
decided to try it and this guy
but when the position actually came up a
couple of moves later he couldn't really
figure out why he had liked to move in
the first place if we see after Islands
replying c3 which is I guess just the
best move white needs to capture and now
Queen a5 is so black has abandoned the
the pawn that he had the C pawn but it's
gotten a very active position the knight
here is just not very well placed and
what what do you do with this piece is
also see three hanging Kramnik played
Queen to c1 it doesn't look too active
but let's say the normal-looking move
Queen here is also a bit problematic
after Bishop a6 black a threatening rook
pH which would already basically win the
night if white Mason makes it nothing
move you you will lose this Knight
so very uncomfortable already white
probably needs to do something like that
and and return the pawn after which
there's simply nothing going on very
important after the e pawn falls in any
case in any line this point on d5 gets
available for black's knight this is
very important with the e pawn missing
with the e pawn on the board and then
some lines white could actually play E
for and take the square and this is why
I'm regaining the e2 pawn is very
valuable for black yeah Queen b3 is not
really doing much quincy one was played
and now Bishop a6 we see that black has
very active pieces and the knight is
simply not good yes he form I I think
there really is not not much else rook
c8 yeah here you could debate if maybe
Luke fc8 also was good but drew kz8
seems fine yeah idea kramnik took a
while and then took on a 7 which is
basically admitting that there is not
not much going on um what else could he
do the other there also wasn't pretty
the movie loop do you wanna just I think
a bit a bit more testing for black but I
think he will have enough play anyway
one key point is that black legs idea is
to capture here and play commit to a six
in this exact position it is not so
precise because of roopd six we look at
this what will take here and well black
has some compensation it's probably not
enough but black can actually prepare
that whole procedure by probably playing
Knight to d5 this is a good move to
block the default something like that is
probably right and now black will take
on c4 later very difficult to find and
improving now for white you have a bit
tied up this is six moves by the way is
designed to protect g7 sounds weird but
look at this this is actually a nice
trick White has this check to unpin
himself maybe not even the best move but
black can simply play this move f6 to
make sure there's nothing happening on
g7 and it's not clear if White has any
improving move if white plays nothing
moves just to show it then you can
really safely capture and get the get
the knight back rook t1 was still a bit
more testing but okay chronic took on a
seven and now Bishop c4 yeah and the
line now is completely forced why it
needs to take Chapman a7 with a check 23
the only move and yeah okay now black
cannot just simply take this leaves the
a pawn on the board but you can play
Queen to a6 and this is the main point
this Knight is now a attacked two times
it had to move of course to e5 it is now
Roxy - which is basically a double
attack in tone yeah white needs to
return one point play 293 covering e2 95
yeah black could also take I think yeah
I think it could also take there is not
much wrong with that but I guess he
figured gaining a tempo can cannot be
wrong and e4 yeah here Anna also could
have taken on f2 maybe here I was afraid
that white will have a very very minimal
edge in this position
maybe yeah that's not really the case
but I can understand that he was
thinking that okay my knight is attacked
I don't have this d5 point and let's say
for example 90 f6 probably not not the
best move actually then something like
that could actually be slightly annoying
with pressure on f7 Queen a3 is just
very precise it detects the night and
the night does not have any a great
place to go if you go to e5 you can even
activate your mighty M yeah this was
played and Queen d3 and now this
happened yeah first glance you think
okay is this maybe a bit better for
white with the e6 pawn yeah
it's it's really not it's really too
little even if white would get the pawn
it's still very very dry and Queen e1
was playing at 25 this is a good spot
for black to counter-attack 23 aged 60 i
Dwight has no way to strengthen the
position he played just rook e1
okay 396 and here they agreed to a draw
yeah I understand not a very exciting
game but a very important game for Anand
and
the tournament as he has drawn another
black game that could become
uncomfortable if something is going
wrong but we simply playing very
precisely in this tournament not making
any sort of blunders or whatever I mean
night a3 is probably not the most
testing idea ever but he completely
equalized against it and you still need
to do that there are ways to go wrong
and this is very simply very good play
you're not great for the spectators but
you need to you need to play those
drawers to to qualify at the end you the
wind's happened elsewhere yeah and
chrome leak after yesterday's terrible
loss against Sweden lights it's
understandable that he wasn't yeah he
said that he was just trying to play a
game and didn't prepare like ours also
couldn't find any sleep it's very
understandable after that came so where
he tried an idea in a solid opening um
like the Catalan and try to do know
something if nothing materializes then
it's a draw and this is what happened
all right I hope you like the coverage
anyway maybe got some opening knowledge
out of it in case you play the opening
with either colour yeah thanks for
watching